Congratulations. This is really impressive.
You've gotten all the way through the course.
The only thing left is the final, and good luck on that.
Now I'd like to ask you to challenge us to improve this course.
We'd like your help with that.
We'd like you to tell us how you think that we can improve this course,
and what other topics in theoretical computer science you would like to learn about.
We have a link to a survey that we'd really appreciate it if you took,
down below the video in the instructor comments.
Once you've taken this survey go ahead and check this box,
and then good luck on the final.
Once again I'd like to thank you for being a part of this course.